what is lacking nutrient-wise when you have a
split nail whether it's in your fingernail or
your toenail there's a medical condition
called anacostia this is a fancy turn for
you have brittle nails or split nails soft
nails fin nails or peeling of your nails
now it could be low iron in some
cases could be low amounts of biotin
but the most likely cause is low
calcium it's a calcium deficiency now
you could also be low in vitamin d that's
preventing you from absorbing calcium
but this is the most common reason for split
nails all right the best calcium source
would be something like calcium lactate calcium
orotate calcium citrate but do not do the calcium
carbonate okay why because it takes like 12
different steps for your body to absorb that
and you could also do a high quality cheese
as well like maybe organic grass-fed cheese
from europe that would be also a good way
to get your calcium other symptoms of a
calcium deficiency would be fatigue weak grip
strength muscle aches twitching weakened bones
they're brittle or you have cramping it could be
in your feet it could be in your calf there's some
other symptoms as well like little tingling around
your lips like it's called paresthesia but this
is probably the most likely reason why you have
split nails and you can easily get some calcium
lactate or oratate or citrate and resolve this
problem all right thanks for watching hey before
you go real quick i have a course entitled how to
bulletproof your immune system it's a free course
i want you to take it and here's why here's you
here is your environment everyone is focused on
this over here avoiding your environment but
what about here what about strengthening your
immune system that's what's missing this course
will show you how to bulletproof yourself and so
you can tolerate and resist your environment
much better by strengthening your own immune
system i put a link down in the description right
down below check it out and get signed up today